foreign
let's get started um
welcome back everyone
um so for the second day of the uh
Simon's fellows uh meet the fellows
event for fall 2022 so we have two
sessions to round off uh this uh lovely
event
um so the first session the before talks
and the first talk was given by Gautam
goyal on competitive country
thanks speaker for the introduction so
hi I'm kafum I'm a postdoc here at the
Simons Institute I just graduated from
Caltech a few months ago uh today
everything I'll be talking about is
joint work with my PhD advisor uh babaka
CB right so I want to start off by
giving a very brief introduction to
control theory so what is control
control is a branch of mathematics that
studies how you regulate or stabilize
evolving dynamical systems right so in
this spelling 747 uh maybe this building
747 has some autopilot and this
autopilot will guide the plane where it
needs to go even if the plane is sort of
perturbed by turbulence or storms or
things like that and here in this
insulin pump you know the user is eating
food and that food is raising their
blood sugar and the insulin pump will
dynamically regulate their blood sugar
by injecting insulin so we're sort of
keeping the blood sugar at the desired
level so in both examples uh there's
some algorithm that sort of guides the
system in towards desirable directories
and avoids undesirable trajectories
great so one of the most uh widely
studied models for control is called
linear quadratic control so here's how
it looks so there's this state X the
state of the system and the state
evolves according to this linear
equation so the next state at time t
plus one is a linear combination of the
previous state x t my control input UT
which the algorithm selects and some
external disturbance WT which is sort of
exogenous the algorithm has no control
over it so the WT might represent the
turbulence or it might represent the
spike in blood sugar once when the you
know user eats something so so the the
WT is selected by Nature it's outside of
the algorithm's control
and uh the algorithm uh incurs some
costs in each time step and this cost
has two terms the first term represents
how desirable the state is is the state
where we want it to be and the second
term you can think of as a regularizer
it penalizes the algorithm for investing
a lot of energy or work in the control
action right and the real world it
always takes some work to guide my plane
where I want it to go right it takes
fuel for example so the second term sort
of represents that fact that I have to
put energy into stabilizing the system
and this talk I'll assume that the
Dynamics are known and the inter
condition is X naught equals zero and
for Simplicity I will also assume that
these uh matrices q and R are just the
identity but I want emphasize that's
only for the talk it just makes the talk
simpler in general they can be arbitrary
positive definite matrices
and uh
this is an online problem in each time
step the control the controller uh can
pick a control action UT given the
history of disturbances observed so far
but that is not allowed to use
information about the future right so
the controller can say here's what I've
observed and now here's the action I'll
pick this is a little bit like in
Bandits where uh in each round I pick an
arm given the history of losses I've
observed so far but of course I don't
know anything about the future losses
and the goal of the online algorithm is
very simple it's to minimize its uh cost
over all rounds and I'll just mention as
an aside that I've allowed the policy pi
to be time varyings I've allowed it to
be indexed by time this also happens in
Bandits where the beginning I do
exploration at the end I do exploitation
so the policy is varying
okay and let me just introduce some
notation very quickly
um I'll when I describe a variable
without a subscript I mean the full
sequence okay and I'll let the energy of
a sequence uh simply be the sum of the
squared L2 Norms of its components this
energy is sort of a measure of how big a
sequence is in some sense
and uh with this convention that q and R
are the identity the cost incurred by
the controller has a very simple form
it's simply the energy in X plus the
energy in you
yeah great
so there's two classical approaches to
control one of them is called H2 control
this is very simple we assume that the
disturbance is generated stochastically
and the goal of the controller is to
minimize its expected cost there's a
more sophisticated approach to control
which is very popular in the 1980s
called H Infinity control so in this
model we take a worst case perspective
and we model control the Minimax game
played between the controller and nature
which is selecting the W's and the goal
of nature is to try to find a
disturbance
uh which is small in energy but which
forces the controller to incur at a high
cost and the controller's goal is to be
robust to this situation to try to
minimize this ratio so the intuition is
the controller is saying well yeah you
can make me incur high cost but you
better put a lot of energy into that
disturbance right you you can't just
give me a tap and it'll cause me to fall
over it has to be like a really
concerted effort
um and we know both theoretically and
empirically that that you can't mix and
match in other words if you take an H2
controller or look at its worst case
performance it's lousy if you take an H
Infinity controller look at its
performance in a stochastic setting it's
lousy so this motivates the uh design of
controllers which will try to perform
well no matter how the disturbance is
generated
that's what this talk is about so I'm
going to look at control to the lens of
competitive analysis which anupam talked
about in his boot camp lecture so here's
the idea uh again model control is a
Minimax game but instead of comparing
the cost of the online algorithm to the
energy of the disturbance I'll instead
compare it to the cost of this
Clairvoyant offline optimal controller
which is the controller that selects the
optimal sequence of control actions
given full knowledge of the disturbance
sequence W so it's saying sort of
counterfactually if you could have if
you did have perfect information about
the past and the future what is the
optimal sequence of control actions and
the intuition is that if my competitor
ratio is low then I'm closely tracking
the optimal possible performance right
because the offline optimal sort of the
globally optimal controller so if this
is low I'm good no matter how the
sequence is generated and uh the idea is
to reduce this problem to uh H Infinity
control in a synthetic system so they're
both Mini Max Games and you know you you
give me some matrices A and B driven by
some disturbance W I'll construct some a
prime B Prime and synthetic disturbance
W Prime such that the uh control action
selected by an H Infinity controller in
the synthetic system exactly coincide
with the competitive with the optimal
competitive ratio control actions in the
original system
okay it's a reduction
okay let me just sketch this out briefly
um so okay so there's this linear
Dynamics equation and we start off with
this initial condition X naught if I
plug that in I can solve for X1 just
plugging that into the Dynamics and I
can plug that in and get x2 I can plug
that in and so on and so forth and what
I can do is I can rewrite uh each of the
X's as a linear combination of all the
previous disturbances and all the
previous control inputs and I can
collect that linear system in a big
Matrix equation okay so I'll call I'll
say that this Matrix equation is X is
equal to f u plus GW where f is this
Matrix that Maps U into X and G is this
Matrix that Maps W and X okay and the
thing I like about this f and g is that
it that sort of gives me like the sort
of global view of how how the full
sequence of x's and U's and W's are
related and uh the nice thing is that
the offline optimal cost has a very
simple form it's simply a quadratic
function in this W's in terms of these F
and G's
and since I uh I can now rewrite the
competitive control problem uh in this
form so what I've done here is I've
simply taken the offline optimal cost
and I plugged it in the denominator
right so that's the denominator of the
ratio the online the thing in uh the
numerator the online cost we said it was
the sum of the energy in X and the
Androgen W but we also agree that the
state's X have this linear form feu
equals GW right so this ratio is exactly
the competitive ratio we saw before okay
and the goal is again is to minimize
that ratio over all policies okay
um
one more slide okay okay thank you um
yeah so
um here's what I'll do so I'm going to
sketch out this reduction so I'll Define
delta to be sort of this kolesky factor
of the Matrix I plus FF transpose right
so I plus FF transpose is certainly a
positive definite it has a plus key
factorization and I'll let Delta be this
plus key factor and I'll Define the
synthetic disturbance W Prime to Simply
Be Delta inverse GW okay so why did I
pick that one why why am I calling that
W Prime well there's a few nice things
that happened
so my Dynamics uh X is equal to f u plus
GW they can be Rewritten in terms of w
Prime instead of w right because uh the
Delta here will cancel the Delta inverse
so I just get back the exactly the
equation I had before okay and my
offline cost uh which we agreed was a
quadratic function of w has a very
simple description in terms of w Prime
and simply the energy in W Prime okay so
the competitive ratio I showed you on
the previous slide has uh the following
form
um it's the so so in the denominator we
have the energy in W Prime and on the
numerator we have the cost increded by
the online algorithm but now it's in the
synthetic system Fu plus uh plus Delta W
Prime okay so I've Rewritten the
competitive ratio problem as an H
Infinity problem in the synthetic system
uh Fu you know X is equal to f u Plus
Delta W Prime driven by the synthetic
determines W Prime so this shows the
connection what I haven't shown you so
far is how you do this efficiently right
if someone came to you and said I have
these huge T by T block matrices f and g
and you factor them No One's Gonna no
engineer is actually going to run that
you can show that you can actually do
this efficiently and that's the hard
problem so you can actually simplify
this quite a bit and get a very explicit
form for the competitive controller it's
not gonna have time to talk about that
interested come chat with me uh thanks
for listening
thanks a lot
any questions forgotten
so yeah thanks for a really nice talk uh
so it seems that uh competitive control
is somewhat between H2 and H Infinity
right is that any other notion that
interpolates goes between each two to H
Infinity yeah that's a great question um
so in this talk I looked at the ratio
between the online and offline costs
it's also natural to look at the
difference right so this is sometimes
called regret and especially Dynamic
regret so I have a parallel line of work
uh on Dynamic regret that studies how
you look at differences and there's also
more restrictive Notions of regret like
policy or bad and static regret which
other people looked at and it turns out
that there are actually a lot of
surprising connections so for example uh
it's when doing regret minimization it's
common to use some sort of gradient
descent online gradient descent you can
show that the algorithms I described
also have a collection to Guardian
descent so I'm not going to have time
I had a quick question so this so there
should be some restriction on Pi that it
is causal right exactly so when you make
transform to this W Prime the synthetic
thing how do you model that that is an
excellent question so that you you know
that so so okay so so uh this Matrix G
is causal that represents the fact that
my my states only depend on the previous
part this Delta it has to also be causal
okay if Delta is also a causal lower
triangular then Delta inverse GW will
also be causal and that means that my
disturbance my synthetic disturbance at
time T is only a linear function a
linear combination of the previously it
observed disturbances so you're
absolutely right I have to keep track of
causality to make sure that I can
implement this in the real world my
controller can't depend on the future
right and then that Delta is in fact yes
yes it actually actually Yes actually
there are infinitely many kilosky
factors but there's only one unique
causal one and you can find it
explicitly I didn't yeah that's your
question
questions okay
um thanks again
[Applause]